The husband of a missing
mother of three
searched online
about how to dispose of a 115 pound
woman's body.
That's according to two
law enforcement sources
who shared the information
to CNN.
Goodness.
Well, that's
just one of the disturbing
new revelations
about the disappearance
of an Walsh
to a picture of her there.
Her husband, Brian Walsh,
he has now been charged
with misleading authorities.
CNN's
Jason Carroll is live in
Cohasset, Massachusetts.
So, Jason, we're also learning
that authorities were searching
two locations last night.
I wonder,
do we know the significance
of those searches
Well,
they could end up being very,
very significant.
It's still early on
in this investigation.
But as you were saying,
much of that search
and that investigation
shifted here
from the home in Cohasset
to two facilities,
one that last night
at a trash facility
in North Boston.
That's where investigators,
Jim, spent hours
combing through
some of the garbage there,
looking for more evidence
in their case.
In addition to that,
yesterday,
late afternoon
or early evening,
they also spent some time
sifting through the rubble
at a dumpster
outside of Walsh's,
his mother's home,
searching that facility
there as well.
All of this
as a source tells
CNN that investigators
also found
very disturbing
Internet searches
that Walsh had conducted
following his wife's
disappearance, which included
how to dispose of a £115 body
and also how to
dismember a body and incredibly
disturbing details
about this case,
which we also heard yesterday
in court
during Walsh's arraignment,
where prosecutors
laid out
what they say investigators
found at the home
when he's on
surveillance at that time
purchasing about $450
worth of cleaning supplies.
That would include
mops, bucket tops,
Twix,
drop cloths,
as well as various
kinds of tape.
Blood was found
in the basement area,
as well as a knife,
which also contained some blood
during the time for him
when he didn't
report his wife
and gave various statements
that allowed him
time to be clean of evidence.
And we should also tell you
that reached out
to the district
attorney's office
talking to them
this morning, Jim and Erica
expecting to get
some more information,
possibly about their case
that should be happening
later today.
Again, at this point,
Walsh has just been charged
with misleading police.
We'll see if that changes
in the near future.
Also, I should point out,
I spoke to a friend
of mine
who was on the phone, a man
by the name of Peter Kirby.
He told me,
as you can expected,
they are extremely,
extremely devastated,
he says,
by all of the developments
that they've been hearing about
in the news.
He said at this point,
their focus is on
Anna's three small children.
Joining us now,
Deborah Norville,
the host of Inside Edition,
which is, by the way,
celebrating its
35th anniversary.
Congratulations for that,
Deborah.
It's always good to see you.
I wish we were talking about
something better,
but this morning
thank you so much
for joining us. Good morning.
Absolutely.
Your reaction to this news,
especially in the context of
its proximity to the place.
Brian Walsh told
investigators he had visited
Yeah, this is
a case that's developing
pretty quickly
now that authorities
are actually have
the opportunity
to investigate it.
In the big news
overnight,
it's been reported
that evidence linked to
the disappearance
was the garbage
transfer facility.
And Peabody,
that's the latest place
for cops have been looking
across the board story
that Brian Walsh
has told investigators
since his wife was last seen
by someone outside
the family on New Year's Eve.
Actually about one
30 in the morning
on January 1st
has simply not added up
to what the facts are that
they're developing.
They had had a friend over
for dinner.
The friend left about one
30 in the morning.
The forensics,
everything was just fine.
Brian Walsh told investigators
that his wife had
to suddenly go
to Washington, D.C.,
where she worked
as a real estate
executive on January 1st.
And then later didn't
show up to work.
She wasn't reported missing
until January 4th.
It's what happened
between January 1st
and January 4th
that investigators
are looking at
and they're able to follow
the movements of Brian Walsh
because he was already
under house arrest
for a federal fraud case
for which
he was awaiting sentencing
during that period.
He went to as prosecutors
told the judge
in court yesterday,
he went to a Home Depot
where he wore surgical gloves
head on a COVID mask and paid
cash for $450
worth of cleaning supplies.
That fact
really got investigators
attention.
They then were able to
do a search
of the gentleman's home,
and that's where they found
not only the bloody knife
in the basement,
but also blood in the basement.
Presumably efforts
would be made to clean that up.
That hadn't happened yet.
And subsequent to that,
they got the arrest warrant
for impeding the investigation.
Because statements
Brian Walsh
made did not back up
to the fact that they had some
surveillance that
they were doing.
What about the
Google searches, Deborah?
How specific
they were when the searches
Yeah,
the Google search
is very troubling.
I can't tell you exactly
when that Google search
was made.
That hasn't been reported.
This is actually a source
that CNN has
that developed
this information.
But there were two things
that were troubling
to investigators.
Not only did he look up
allegedly
how to dispose of a £115 woman
He also allegedly looked at
how to dismember a body.
And this is yet
another example of,
you know, we've all seen
these crime cases
where you have to wonder,
don't people
who are contemplating
committing crimes realize
the digital footprint
they leave behind
is impossible to erase.
They will be discovered
if they have looked these
things up.
Yeah,
that's what
we were talking about
this morning.
The fact that those are
the searches
that have been found here
in the evidence,
he has been,
you know, charged,
but just
with misleading investigators
do you think that's just
in order to hold him
as they are
figuring out
more things,
learning about
the actions he took
and where he was in the days
after her disappearance?
Exactly.
And it also puts
a pin on any other actions
that he might be
contemplating taking.
As we said,
there was blood
in the basement
of the family home.
If you have committed a crime,
that is something
you would want to get rid of.
I was surprised
when the prosecutor
was detailing
the items
that were purchased
at Home Depot.
If these were the actions
of a guilty individual,
you would think
you'd be purchasing
cleaning supplies,
including bleach or something,
to actually
get rid of any DNA material
that may be there.
I should note that
we don't yet
know what
the results of the DNA testing
on that bloody knife might be,
but that's something
that investigators
are obviously working right now
to try to develop a Deborah.
You know,
we do these stories
and we focus on the clues
and who the suspect is.
We have to remember
there are families
involved in friends
and loved ones
who are waiting to
find out what happened to this
this woman.
And they're all.
And those children
going children.
Absolutely.
Well, right now, yeah,
there are three little boys.
And it's interesting
the woman is
the missing woman's
from Serbia.
And her mother has granted
an interview
and says that her daughter
called her
just after Christmas
and asked her to
please come
to America to visit.
She said, I'm 69 years old.
I can't move on the dime.
I've got to get my
medication, etc.
She now has expressed regret
that she didn't
honor that
request and get to this
right away.
You're right.
There's families involved.
Yeah,